The dealerships just don't really know
if we can add remote start and the
tailgate assist. Well, we're gonna find
out because I think this truck was
manufactured with those features. I'm
about to show you the fastest, easiest
way to go from one key to having a spare
with the help of Tom's Key company, this
little programming device, and the magic
of our keyphoto key cutting service.
Let's jump in this 2020 Silverado and
watch the magic. If you only have one
key for your vehicle, guess what? You're
like over half of used car owners. Most
used vehicles are sold with a single key
or fob. And we all know we want a
second. If you lose the only key you've
got, disaster is waiting to happen. So
come to tomskey.com. We'll help you make
a spare. You'll save hours of time and
hundreds of dollars in the process. My
friend Spencer bought this used Fire
Engine Red 2020 Silverado. And he
reached out to me when he sent me a
picture of his key fob. I was a bit
surprised. It was just a basic remote
with lock, unlock, and panic function.
On our website, tommskey.com, we
typically sell the five button version
for a 2020 Silverado. That includes the
remote start feature and the power
tailgate functions. Now, his original
key has the Chevy logo on the back,
which most likely means it's an original
key from the truck was manufactured. I
told my friend that he was going to end
up with remote start. Let's see if I'm
right. All right, let's make a spare
key. Got the original key with the tile
key finder. Pairs to a smartphone, which
you can always find your vehicle. It's
got the Chevy logo. Now, this one looks
really worn. A little funny. And here's
the new key. Let's see if remote start
and tailgate lift assist end up working
when we add this. All going well. This
vehicle should have remote start and the
power liftgate because the vehicle
sticker and all the RPO codes say that
this truck was manufactured with those
features. Now, it is a 2020 year model
and that was the year there were all
sorts of circuit board supply chain
issues. some vehicles that didn't have
all the features they were supposed to
be manufactured with. All right, let's
get started. We need to scan the QR code
on the programmer to get going with the
app. With our pair my key app installed,
we can go ahead and begin the
programming. Start here. First step is
getting this guy plugged into the OBD
port. The OBD port is right down by your
gas and brake pedal. Plug this guy in.
I recommend picking up this optional
extension cable so you can see what's
going on with the programmer. We see
it's got power here. So, let's go ahead
and continue. Next step, we need to get
the Bluetooth pairing done. It's going
to find the serial number on your
programmer. You want to watch for the
comm light to turn on. There we got this
guy paired. We can go ahead and begin
programming. Now, I do want to point out
there's technical support available.
That's during regular business hours,
and they do great. You can call them up.
There's a phenomenal support team
that'll walk you through any problems.
We're here to make sure you have success
making a new key or fob for your
vehicle. All right, let's get underway.
We to enter license plate information.
Sometimes you'll get this warning. It
can't find the car. That's okay. You can
select manually. This is a Chevy
Silverado
and it's 2020. This is important. Some
vehicles have multiple types of devices.
Remotes to lock and unlock the doors
only, a regular key you put in the
ignition to turn, or a smart key, which
is what we have here, where you push the
start button. So, let's select our smart
key. Important tips. We want to keep the
app open. Don't change to other apps
while you're working on this. Be sure
you've got all your working keys. In
this case, we have one with you as well
as our new key. And we want a strong
cell signal or Wi-Fi connection. It
should take just 15 minutes. So, if it
takes longer, you're going to want to
call technical support. You can contact
them right there. Let's get going.
Initiating programming. Okay. Couple
things I want to tell you about. We've
got our Bluetooth. That'll probably
disappear as during part of the
programming. Make sure you're not
drawing the battery down on your
vehicle. Turn off your headlights. Don't
have the radio or the HVAC running. Roll
the windows down if it's a hot day. You
don't want to drain your vehicle
battery. On a lot of General Motors
vehicles like Chevy, GMC, Buick,
Cadillac, if the programming gets
interrupted partway through, it'll seem
like your original key is no longer
working. But never fear, you just have
to get the vehicle computer reset.
That's as simple as disconnecting the
vehicle battery, waiting a few minutes,
reconnecting it, and the computer should
be reset and not stuck in programming
process. While we're waiting for this,
let me show you something else. This is
really important because if your vehicle
battery ever dies or the fob battery
dies, you're not going to be able to get
in unless you have the emergency
keyblade cut. And we have this awesome
key by photo technology. You simply add
the key by photo service to your order
and then you'll upload photos of your
existing key and we will cut your new
key so it arrives already fitting your
vehicle. All right, we're almost ready.
Here we go. Okay, please wait. Notice
the Bluetooth connection just dropped
off. That should come back. There we
are. During programming, it's pretty
normal to have some lights flashing and
things. Gives us specific instructions.
Now, the app's going to improve over
time, so make sure you follow the
instructions in the app. The vehicle
engine is turned off, not running. We're
going to turn on our hazard lights. With
those going, let's continue
communicating. Please wait. The hazard
lights stop blinking. All right, we've
got a pin code 114. You might want to
jot that down. I think the app should
remember it, but 11 194. Configuring the
system. Please wait 45 seconds. Okay.
Oh, my light started blinking again. I'm
seeing some things happen on the
dashboard. Dashboard turned off. The
hazards are still blinking. All right.
Put the new keyless remote into the
programming slot area. This is located
either in the center console or in the
cup holder. If you can't locate it,
refer to the keys, doors, windows
section of the owner's manual. Okay, so
we got to take our new remote and find
the programming slot. We're going to
start by looking in here. Can tell my
buddy just bought this vehicle because
there's not much in here. I'm not seeing
a programming slot in there unless it's
under here. Let's look under this mat.
Still not seeing it. Okay, center cup
holder. Sometimes this rubber part comes
out. Again, I'm not seeing it there.
Sometimes it'll be this section right
there. So, let's pull out the trusty
owner's manual. See what we can find.
Here we go. The owner's manual.
Transmitter pocket with bucket seats.
So, it does look like it's in the center
section right there. So, let's hope we
haven't taken too long. We're going to
put our new key right down there. All
right. Quick through the next screens to
safely exit programming. Okay, so the
app seems to pick up. It's taken me a
little while here. Let's go ahead and
hit continue and see what happens. Oh,
look at that. Dashboard lit up.
Verifying vehicle security. Please wait.
Logo turned on over there. Lights are
flashing. Oh, here we go. We seem to be
in progress. Security system wait timer.
Please wait for 10 minutes. Okay, so
this goes back to that notice that
sometimes it can take up to 15 minutes.
Here's one thing I'm noticing as it's
counting up. Take a look on the
dashboard here. See the little security
light with a lock in the car? That's a
security indication and commonly
associated with programming a car key.
So, it's a good thing that that's turned
on right now. Now, I'm noticing this
light is turned on green here. That's
also a good sign. Meanwhile, let's call
the Chevy dealership and see what see
what they say about upgrading to remote
start. I'm trying to find out uh I've
got a used 2020 Silverado and I'm trying
to figure out if I can like get remote
start on it. What it takes to get remote
start. Right now, my remote just has
lock and unlock.
Lock and unlock. If if it doesn't come
with auto start, that's not a feature
you can add on, unfortunately.
Okay. One other question. What does it
take just to get a spare key? I've got
one key for this used truck. What does
that cost?
Is it a is it a push to start key where
you actually have to physically push the
car to start it or or do you have a key
insert where you have to just put the
key in?
Yeah. So, you push the button to start
it?
Push button. Those roughly run around
anywhere from $580 to $600.
Ooh. Okay. Pretty spendy. $580 to $600.
How long does that take?
Couple hours. Couple hours.
About a three, worst case scenario, 5
hour case scenario cuz it does require a
software update. It could be quick or
something could take a little bit of
time.
Okay. So, plan on like half a day at
least then. All right. Thank you so much
for the help.
Can you believe that? That's absolutely
crazy. $580 to $600 at the Chevy
dealership to make a spare key fob. And
they want the car to be there for as
long as 5 hours. That's absolutely
crazy. At Tom's Key Company, you'll save
hundreds of dollars and hours of time
skipping the car dealership. So, you get
the idea how these calls are going. The
dealerships just don't really know if we
can add remote start and the tailgate
assist. We're making some good progress.
Not quite there. Here's a helpful tip to
know. If your FOB battery has died, you
might be concerned you won't be able to
start your engine. And the key won't
work unless you put it into the
programming slot. Then the vehicle's
sensor can read the fob even if the
battery is dead and you'll be able to
start the engine. So tuck that in the
back of your mind in case your fob
battery dies. Just going to hold this up
here cuz sometimes we approach the end
of 10 minutes. It'll actually end before
the 10 minutes is reached. Okay, we
should be done within about 3 minutes.
All right, there we go. Configuring
system. Please wait. I'm noticing that
security light turned off. Oh, there it
turned back on. So again, things going
on with the vehicle computer. The light
on my push button start ended. Oh, now
notice it says ready for remote number
five. So, that's interesting because
that tells me there's actually been four
remotes programmed to that vehicle
before, but we'll talk about the number
of remotes in a minute. Click the start
button one time. Wait five seconds.
Okay, here we go.
One, two, three, four, five. All right,
look at this. Ready for remote number
six. You see that? It looks like we just
programmed a remote and it was remote
number five. If the number does not go
up, click the start button again. Double
check you have the remote in the proper
area. If the dashboard is blacked out,
continue programming the steps anyway.
This is common in Cadillacs. Okay, so
there's some warnings there. This app
will continue to get better. Programming
keys has some tricks sometimes. So,
let's continue configuring the system.
Please wait. Now, this is interesting.
Dashboard's flashing. The blinking sound
of the emergency flasher stopped. Oh,
now it's started again. Right. So,
there's definitely stuff going on with
the vehicle computer. Now, asked me if
we have any additional new keys. We want
to program the vehicle. No, we don't.
We're done. Configuring the system.
Please wait. Now, this is a part where
it can get a little tricky with GM
vehicles. We want to make sure we
complete these final steps. Otherwise,
it'll seem like no keys are working. But
don't worry, we can recover them with
the vehicle battery being unplugged. If
the dashboard is turned on, click the
start button once to turn the ignition
off. Dashboard is turned on, so I'm
gonna click the start button once. Okay,
it turned off and the green light on the
button turned off. Press and hold the
vehicle start button for 15 seconds.
Then click continue. This is the very
important step. 15 seconds. One, two,
three. Oh, it's giving me a timer.
Excellent. And if you don't complete
this step, it's going to seem like all
your keys have been erased. That's not
really the case. Just the vehicle
computer got froze up. Okay, the ready
for remote message should no longer be
displayed. Yep, it's gone. If the
message has not gone away, press and
hold the start button for another 12 to
15 seconds. So again, that holding the
start button is a key thing. If that
doesn't get done quite properly, it'll
seem like your remotes are all erased.
Again, they're not erased. Just have to
get get the vehicle computer unfrozen.
All right, since the ready for remote
message is gone, we can hit continue.
Please wait. Do not push the brake
pedal. Press and hold the start button
for 6 to 10 seconds till the dashboard
is fully turned on. Okay, so here we go.
1 2 3 4 5 6 Oh, there. See it all flash
on? Eight nine 10. All right, so I think
my dashboard's fully turned on. We got
all the lights all over. All right, here
we go. Let's hit continue. Configuring
the system. Please wait. Let's hit
continue. Configuring the system. Please
wait. All right. Press the start button
for 2 seconds to turn the ignition off.
Okay. 100 1,002. All right. The light on
the button turned off. The dashboard
turned off. We haven't started the
engine in any of this process. Okay.
It's important to be aware of. Open and
close the driver's door once. Okay.
Opening the door.
Closing the door. The horn beeped at us.
Hit continue. Configuring the system.
Wait about 30 seconds. Now, remember how
our new key fob has power tailgate? I'm
noticing it's right here on this truck.
This symbol is giving me hope that the
remote will do the trick as well. All
right, hold the brake pedal and push the
start button to start the engine. All
right, I got my foot on the brake. I'm
pushing the button to start the engine.
Boom. The truck fired up. That's good.
Now remember, if the truck doesn't fire
up, you can call tech support. They'll
walk you through it. You just need to
disconnect the vehicle battery. Okay,
let's hit continue, click the start
button to turn the engine off.
Okay, engine is turned off. Continue
configuring the system. Please wait.
Open and close the driver's door once.
Okay, opening the door.
Close the door. Vehicle beeped.
Continue. Press the lock button and then
the unlock button on the new remote.
Listen for the locks to click. Okay,
this is the moment of truth. We're going
to press the lock button and then the
unlock button. Lock. Unlock. Okay, the
lock didn't actually move, but I heard
it click. Sorry, that click was pretty
faint. Let's hit continue. If you heard
the locks click, click continue. If the
locks did not respond, make sure the
remote has a new battery. Go ahead and
click this again.
Okay, definitely clicked. Hit continue.
Success.
All right. Okay. Beautiful. We've got a
new remote. Let's check that our lock
and unlock functions work. Here's our
existing remote. Here's the old remote.
It still works. Here's the new remote.
Excellent. It works. I'm going to get my
programmer unplugged.
Oh, look at this. The app tells me
there's five keys programmed. That
reminds me. Remember how I was a little
uncertain about this key fob? Because we
now have five remotes programmed. We've
got one remote here, one remote there.
That means there's three other remotes
lost somewhere in the world. Almost
certainly the two remotes that came when
this vehicle was manufactured are some
of those ones lost out in the world. And
then somebody had new remotes made, they
lost one of them, and we're down to this
single one. This is remote number four.
This is remote number five. So, we're
going to find out in just a minute if
the remote start and the power tailgate
worked because maybe whenever this
remote was made, they didn't have the
remote start buttons or or they didn't
know if the remote and tailgate worked,
so they just did one with the lock and
unlock button. Okay, we need to make
sure both these keys are starting the
engine. So, how are we going to do that?
We're going to start by getting both
keys out of the vehicle.
With those keys out of the vehicle, I
just saw a warning. So, when I push the
brake pedal and try to hit the start
button, the engine should not start.
Yep. Nothing's happening. Oh, look at
that. And it's telling me I've got to
place the key in the pocket in the
transmitter pocket to start the vehicle.
So, that's good. That's clearly what we
want because it's not recognizing the
remote.
So, I've climbed out of the truck with
one remote. Now, we should be able to
start the engine. And if it starts, we
know it's this new one.
Boom. Look at that.
Everything fired up. Okay, so that's a
good sign.
Now, let's check the original one.
Okay, we can bring back in our original
one. Let's make sure it starts the
engine.
Boom. Excellent. Truck fires up. Both
remotes are working. So, with that,
we've got two remotes. the existing one
that turned out to be remote number four
for this truck and the new one, remote
number five. Let's find out about remote
start. This is the moment of truth I've
been waiting for. Does the remote start
work? Let's find out. Here's how to use.
You got to lock the vehicle and then
press and hold remote start for 4
seconds. One, two, three. Look at that.
It works. The vehicle has remote start.
The dealerships didn't even know. We
just made a spare key for my friend and
remote start works. So, remote start
worked. So, the tailgate assist should
work as well. Here we go. Click it
twice. Boom. We just got a new key fob
that has the buttons to access the
original features that the truck was
manufactured with, the remote start and
tailgate assist. Be sure you have at
least two keys for your vehicle. And in
the process, you might just get some
surprising upgrades. Can you believe how
easy that was to make a spare key with
the help of Tom's Key company? This
little programming device, the magic of
our key by photo key cutting service.
You've got nothing to lose. At Tom's Key
Company, we stand behind all our
products with a full money back
guarantee, and great customer service.
So, if you run into problems, reach out
to us. Help. Key.com or the phone number
in the app. We'll help you get that new
key working. And if for some reason it
still won't work, no worries. Ship
everything back. you get a full refund.
It's that easy. Tom's Key Company has
saved our customers millions of dollars
by skipping the hassle of the car
dealership and making a spare key
without leaving home. So, come to
tomskey.com and place your order today.
And to find out more of the surprising
story about upgrading to remote start
that 80% of Chevy dealerships didn't
know, be sure you check out the next
video right Here.